Kenneth Claire has spent more than three
decades in prison for the rape and
murder of a young woman in Orange County
California but he's been seeking a
retrial
ever since private eye CJ Ford uncovered
the fact that the County DA had tested
DNA evidence found on the scene and that
it didn't match Claire the District
Attorney office really had it in their
minds that we have the right person and
we're gonna prosecute him and we're
gonna put him on death row and you're
gonna see that he's executed question
question question about what they are
not doing for Kenneth and why they are
holding things that could help him
the Orange County DA withheld the DNA
results from the defense at the time of
Claire's earlier Appeals but this isn't
the only piece of information the county
withheld in this case and prosecutors
withholding favorable information isn't
a problem limited to the Clair case or
to Orange County when it comes to
deciding what evidence a jury should
hear when deciding innocence or guilt
the American criminal justice system
entrusts prosecutors with extraordinary
power the issues in the Clair case
certainly the one that's been getting
the most attention is the DNA results
and the fact that they haven't been
turned over but then in an overall sense
the question is what else may be being
held back Scott Sanders is an assistant
public defender in Orange County he's
made a name for himself by exposing the
fact that county prosecutors recruit
jailhouse informants to solicit
confessions from their fellow inmates in
exchange for reduced sentences and then
testify in court and it's done all
without revealing the nature of the
payoff to the jury the key issue with
incentives is playing by the rules I
mean if you're going to give an
incentive be upfront about it disclose
it to the defense and let jurors and
judges know what's going on that's the
only way you're gonna get a fair trial
if you play games with that you risks
very much the prospect of people being
wrongfully incarcerated jailhouse
informants don't play a role in the
Clair case but Sanders believes that
there are serious problems with at least
two witnesses in the case
the first is Pauline Flores Claire's
ex-girlfriend who supposedly caught
Clair confessing
on tape that's not a confession just
like hey just like leave me alone type
of thing regardless of the credibility
issues with this alleged confession one
big problem is that the prosecutor and
the witness denied to the jury that she
received anything in return for her
cooperation it was only decades later
that she admitted that the police took
care of an outstanding warrant for
wearing a wire and extracting something
that sounded like a confession the
reason why it's important to disclose
information regarding a witness in any
context is jurors are making an
assessment about credibility so if a
witness comes in and says I'm here out
of the goodness of my heart or I'm here
just because I'm interested in helping
the justice system when in fact there's
a benefit one of the issues is an
important issue is should that jury find
the witness credible or not that
credibility determination especially for
a witness like Pauline for Flores is
critical another witness was Margaret
hustling the owner of the house where
the murder occurred who testified that
Claire stole a turquoise charm
belongings to the victim on the night of
the crime Sanders discovered that
hustling was in the middle of a big
welfare fraud case at the time of
Claire's trial prosecutors in that case
downgraded her crime from a felony to a
misdemeanor and a $500 fine after she
provided special info on another case
only 13 days after Claire was convicted
and sentenced to death
jury in the capital case never sees that
she gets this enormous benefit it's bad
enough because it's kind of obvious on
its face but we've seen this pattern in
multiple cases where as soon as the jury
comes to their verdict in the case that
the prosecution's handling they go out
and give a pretty extraordinary
resolution in the witness's case the
prosecutor in the case was a man named
Michael Jacobs he ran Orange County's
Homicide Unit four years and obtained
convictions in several death penalty
cases Michael Jacobs to me and I was
gonna tell you personally very evil
prosecutor he was recognition he likes
the idea of win at all costs were
looking at a prosecutor who on
number of cases did not have discovery
turned over on a number of capital cases
the worry here is what else is out there
that hasn't been turned over Michael
Jacobs won a conviction against a man
named William Charles Payton in 1980 for
a rape and murder after a jailhouse
informant helped secure a death penalty
conviction for the prosecution and
exchange for early release the jury
never knew about the deal and the
informant went on to commit a murder on
the outside California executed Thomas
Thompson in 1998 for a rape and murder
once again the testimony of jailhouse
informants sealed his fate and once
again the jury in the defense never
heard about the deals they cut with the
county the prosecutor in the case was
Michael Jacobs we know he's handled a
lot of homicides he was in the Homicide
Unit for a number of years he was the
head of the homicide unit do we just
assume that somehow in his other cases
he turned over favorable evidence we
should just go on and those people in
custody should die the death that no one
wants which is a death in a prison after
spending many years or should they just
die without having a Rhian in the case I
don't think so I think every one of his
cases should be re-examined Jacobs
declined multiple requests to
participate in this documentary but
Sanders discovered old correspondence
between Jacobs and the state attorney
general's office handling a number of
Appeals in his death penalty cases in
one letter Jacobs complains that the
office finds it necessary to show
everything we have to the defense saying
this is a new concept for me the DA
later fired Jacobs but in its
termination letter didn't cite anything
about his attitude towards withholding
evidence and seemed most upset about his
insulting and demeaning tone when
interacting with the state attorney
general's office what they were learning
in those letters should have been enough
to open investigation about every one of
Michael Jacobs cases once you pass this
line where we lose faith and whether
you're turning over evidence and you're
always turning it over and you're making
that assessment and you're worrying
deeply about defendants rights a case
like clear where there's already
problems boy we should all be worried
but just how widespread is the problem
of withholding evidence in the criminal
justice system this problem is not
limited to Orange County or any one
jurisdiction this is a problem that
we've seen across the whole country you
can see it from our data we found that
there was an inordinate number of cases
involving exactly this problem Cathleen
cookie Ridolfi is a law professor at
Santa Clara University and co-author of
a study on evidence disclosure when you
look at the problems with what
prosecutors do we're always looking at
the prosecutors themselves what we
decided to do was not look at the
prosecutors but look at the courts look
at judges look at judicial rulings to
see to the extent to which what the
courts are doing in some way is either
encouraging non-disclosure or
encouraging disclosure Ridolfi and her
colleagues examined about 5,000 cases
and found 620 where prosecutors withheld
favorable evidence judges ruled that the
withheld evidence only constituted a
violation of law in 22 of those cases
courts are just okay with prosecutors
withholding favorable evidence and
that's really troubling because we know
from post-conviction analysis of DNA
cases that the withholding of favorable
evidence is a key cause of wrongful
conviction another trend of the
researchers uncovered was that
prosecutors were most likely to withhold
evidence in death penalty cases the
truth is actually that finding is
consistent with what I've been finding
in all of our studies which is that you
tend to see more problems in the more
serious cases and I have to I can
speculate and say that the fact that
prosecutors have so much at stake in a
serious case particularly when it's a
death penalty case to win the case their
motivation may be a little greater to
across the line and it's not only that
the cheating gets worse as the stakes
get higher but it appears that the
prosecutors who cheat once tend to do it
again and again Ridolfi found in
california that 1/3 of prosecutorial
misconduct cases were against
prosecutors whom courts had found guilty
of misconduct before without facing
discipline there are primary prosecutors
out there who are doing the right thing
what I say to them is it's important
that we stand together because those
prosecutors who are deviant are actually
they're cutting into the integrity of
the whole system when you
primary objective is to win convictions
it explains all the problems that we're
talking about because the prosecutors
job is to act in the interest of justice
and come up with and reach the right
result not to win convictions if you
want to wait convictions you take
shortcuts you hide evidence you don't
disclose deals you've got to put winning
way secondary to everything else if you
do that if you say look what we want you
to do number one is disclose what you're
supposed to and will live with bet with
bad outcomes will live with acquittals
when they come then the system's gonna
work a lot more fairly one of the
reasons for real concern on a case like
clear is we now identified some issues
for concern and they're pretty
substantial but the real concern
probably more so is what else wasn't
turned over what do you do in those
cases with the failure to disclose that
in the case like clear the right outcome
at the very minimum is to give him a new
trial I couldn't believe that the DA was
sitting on all this evidence now I'm not
testing so I found out that they were
testing it and they knew that the DNA
didn't match Claire's they didn't find
any
Claire's fingerprints they found someone
else's fingerprints but there's nothing
on the crime scene that belongs to
Claire